when you think of scientists with
disabilities the odds are this guy comes
to mind Stephen Hawking overcame his
physical disabilities to become one of
the most renowned physicists of our
generation but he is just one of many
great scientists and engineers who faced
obstacles large and small consider Wanda
D F Wanda is a blind astronomer who can
literally hear the stars she figured out
how to study astronomical data by
converting it into sounds like this
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a gamma-ray burst by the way
there's Thomas Edison one of the
greatest inventors in history he also
happened to be almost entirely deaf
there's Temple Grandin the animal
scientist who helped improve the care of
animals in the livestock industry
she's also autistic and then there's
geneticist Derek Braun who's researching
the roots of the deafness gene it's a
cause that's close to his heart
Derek is deaf and teaches at Gallaudet
University the world's leading
university for the deaf and hard of
hearing we talked to him and his
students about their research as well as
about being a scientist with a
disability the genetics area that I'm
pretty excited about has been a study or
the study of what causes deafness
there's one gene in particular that's
very common it's found everywhere in the
world
now there's between two to four percent
of people who have it as carriers for
that gene and the reason I was so
interested in studying with such people
who study human evolution knows that any
mutation if it has negative side effects
obviously will eventually fall out of
existence but if there's advantages it
will grow and this one has seemed to
grow so we tried to figure out what the
advantage was and means that the
advantage to having this scheme is that
it makes people resistant to certain
diseases and resistance is important for
us as humans to survive I'm hoping that
the research and the findings teach us a
lesson
and the lesson is that as a society we
haven't been very tolerant of different
types of people people with disabilities
or different ways that people be you
know different ways of being diverse we
don't tolerate everyone the same and I
really think we should change our views
and and care more about the diversity
that we have that we have diversity in
genetics and cultural diversity as well
because that diversity is what has made
us stronger if you look at who
scientists are today in the u.s. most
come from a similar group of people one
same group and they only represent maybe
40 percent of the u.s. the remaining 60%
are not represented in the scientific
community but we're missing their ideas
and their intelligence and their hard
work and we want to see recruitment of
everybody from all over the country to
get more of their skills and expertise
Derek and a students shared how they
overcame some of the challenges they
faced and they gave us some advice for
students interested in pursuing science
I didn't always get interpreters when I
needed them that's how I got through a
lot of grad school but I think the
bigger obstacle and the more important
one is people's attitudes a lot of
people look down on depth and other
people with disabilities
and also people feel like I couldn't
deaf people can't and when you hear you
can't from so many people every day
after a while it builds up so my advice
I guess for students who want to become
scientist someday that voice that you
hear is telling you you can't ignore it
and just get rid of it don't even pay
attention to it find a community of
friends who will support you no matter
what I would like to go to graduate
school in the future I would like to get
my PhD in graduate school I'd like to go
for epidemiology to emphasis on public
health and scientific communication and
eventually I want to bridge the gap
between the Deaf and hearing communities
I want to merge them together and
partner
and the reason for that is because the
deaf community doesn't always have
language access and there's information
we don't have access to so I would like
to make sure that in those partnerships
we could get access to the important
work that's going on the scientific
community and to the information that's
being discovered they often don't
accommodate to different levels of
language understanding and the deaf
community oftentimes is left without
access and so I don't want that I want
to add more visual information or visual
interpretation because it's maintaining
my community is important to me and I'm
important to the community and I think
we're all for one and one for all
so I want to make sure that I give back
to my community a lot of people get
pulled down
they don't always graduate from deaf
schools I went to a mainstream school
myself and so I had hearing teachers
that didn't really focus on me they
would focus on who quote-unquote could
talk or had an easier way of
communicating those types of students I
was often kind of cast aside and so I
felt like I wanted to prove them wrong
and the community the deaf community has
contributed to me a lot they told me not
to give up and to keep on moving and to
stay on track I think if anybody wants
to become a scientist go for it don't
allow the world to tell you no or where
you can go or what you can do do it
[Music]